well folks the battlefield beta has come
and gone we've had some amazing moments
and some questionable design choices
with our time in the beta we shot
stabbed crashed blew up and wrote our
way to victory or close to feet and so
to sum it all up here are the five
things we've learned in battlefield ones
open beta impasse Battlefield games it
felt like the air game was an open range
for a select few from fighter jets to
attack choppers many battlefield vets
felt left out of the fun either because
of the lack of aircraft balancing or the
wide gap between casual pilots and
seasoned aces Belva one solves this
problem thanks in part to the error in
which the game takes place will dwell
one aircraft were fast back in their
time whoever here they're slow enough to
control and pack the right amount of
firepower to allow both casual and
hardcore fans jump right into the
cockpit and take to the air with little
worried of feeling overpowered by other
pilots who may have more flight time
than them this makes all the difference
since let's face it when you're attacked
from the air the first thing you want to
do once you jump back in is get your own
aircraft so you can shoot that SOB right
out of the sky but battlefield 1 nails
in the air the at times unfortunately
crash and burn when it comes to
character classes loadout choices the
medic for example was gifted with hard
to control / insane recoil
semi-automatic rifles but then given a
powerful late game unlock grenade
launcher odd weapon choices given the
fact that past meta classes in
Battlefield games main purpose was to
save lives not blow [ __ ] up another our
choice was giving the assault class
practically all the explosives from two
grenade types one for infantry at one
for armor and also to the c4 charges the
assault class and a nutshell is the only
class suitor for taking down armored
vehicles one on one which makes some of
the heavy vehicle based maps feel
extremely one-sided to a particular
class overall though for the most part
the remaining classes do feel balanced
with Scouts dialed in well for the long
range role and support class bringing
the traps and cover fire for their
teammates with plenty of time remaining
before the final release here's hoping
that EA plans to spread out some of
those neat perks and explosives among
the other classes
[Music]
for the first time in recent memory for
me there isn't a single vehicle in
battlefield one so far that doesn't have
its own unique feel and most importantly
ass-kicking firepower to knock your
enemies into next Tuesday everything
from the trench tanks to the artillery
tanks and even the horses all sort of a
very important role and purpose on the
battlefield every vehicle can be used to
push the lines forward or hold them
depending upon the position and of
course the driver or drivers on board
for past Battlefield games most of the
vehicles were used to get to point A to
point B but here they use in a much more
fulfilling role and it's just so
satisfying racking up the kill count on
board one of these things especially the
horse level evolution has always been a
benchmark in the battlefield game since
bad company 1 and here it lives on in a
whole new fashion full building
destruction shell craters aka foxholes
have been given new life here not since
back company to have I ever been drawn
into the role that is battlefield one I
can't tell you how many times I used
kratos for fox hole cover from heavy
machine-gun fire or punched holes
through multiple buildings in order to
tackle on a well-guarded objective on
the other side everything seems to be
handled with care here than in previous
Battlefield games it just feels like EA
finally listened to the screams of
battlefield vets like myself ask him for
the return of full destruction on maps
that being said I'm really hoping that
any city style maps will be handled with
the same destructive force as the alpha
and beta maps have shown
this final add into the series may or
may not be a big hit with battlefield
fans later down the road however it is
due to be mentioned that the behemoth
vehicles that spawn in for the losing
team to help turn things around play a
big part in the games dynamics from
towering Zeppelin's to heavy armored
trains these vehicles spawn in when
needed to help the losing team crawl
back into the fight most importantly
though in the right hands of a squad
these things can lay waste to all comers
ranking up the kill count and making
those objectives a lot easier to capture
many players feel these things although
cool to look at and control are not
needed in battlefield while others
welcome the new add-ons and the
franchise as a first takes a on conquest
mode that many felt needed a good kick
in the pants draw new players in either
way time will tell of this gamble of new
terror vehicles will be welcomed with
open arms or cast aside like an old gum
wrapper and there you have it ladies and
gentlemen my five top things we learn
from battlefield ones open beta it's a
sad day that the beta had to end but for
me I couldn't be more pumped to jump
back into the trenches and take to the
air again once the puh-lease hits did
you have any thoughts about the changes
in the beta good or bad what did you
feel the classes were balanced or
unbalanced in any way feel free to share
your thoughts in the comments below and
until next time I'll see you all on the
battlefield
you